The metro is the most efficient way to get around.
And it shows a real local side to Paris.
Take a ride from one side of town to the other...
...and you'll feel the diversity of the city.
But do note Parisians think it is rude to make eye contact...
...or even smile with strangers in the metro.
And it is impolite to talk loudly among your friends.
Follow those rules and you'll have a more authentic experience.
To buy a ticket for the metro, you can buy one ride for a euro 70.
Or you can buy a billet en carnet for ten tickets at a euro 25 each.
Those tickets work on the bus too, in case you like to travel above ground.
And of course you can always splurge on taxis...
...but if your French is rusty...
...be sure to have your destination written down in French on a piece of paper.
All right, let's talk about my favorite form of transportation in Paris...
...and that is the public bike system called Velib.
There are close to 1800 Velib docking stations, like this one, all around the city...
...with 20,000 bikes in circulation.
That means every 1,000 feet there's a station.
You can purchase a one-day or seven-day pass...
...but sometimes non-European credit cards don't work at the consoles.
So to be safe, I'd book online in advance.